just last September Nvidia released the
GTX 980 the most powerful single GPU on
the market and yet here we are just over
six months later and the company has
given us a new piece of sexy silicon to
lust over but as I noticed in my gtx 980
review that card wasn't the generational
leap in performance you might have
expected enter the gtx titan x a full
fat implementation of invidious power
efficient max or architecture that pairs
are wildly over-the-top twelve gigabytes
of vram with seven teraflops of
processing power it's big its bold and
it's badass but boy is it gonna cost you
so just what you get with the titan ex
headline specs of 3072 cuda cores 96
ROPS and 12 gigabytes of vram tied to a
full fat 384 bit memory system and yes
970 owners before you ask that's a full
12 gigabytes at maximum speed compared
to the gtx 980 the Titan X is clocked
slower by few hundred megahertz but the
vastly higher amounts of CUDA cores and
ROPS more than makes up the difference
and hey if you're into overclocking the
Titan X is 6 + 2 phase design means that
you can crank up the power target to 110
percent pushing the wattage up from 250
to 275 watts yes there's a higher TDP
this time around up from 165 watts of
the GTX 980 unlike AMD's cards though
Nvidia is extremely power efficient
architecture has given the company space
to increase performance without
dramatically increasing TDP and heat or
needing a particularly exotic cooling
solution still you'll need six and eight
pin power from your power supply this
time with nvidia recommending a minimum
of
600 watts to get the job done aside from
the snazzy black exterior the Tison ex
uses the same excellent reference cooler
as Nvidia's other cards however unlike
the gtx 980
nvidia is only allowing partners to
release cards with the reference cooler
so don't expect the likes of MSI's
excellent twin throws a cooling system
to be hitting titans anytime soon
not that it matters too much in testing
the GTX Titan is pretty quiet
although thanks to increased wattage it
is noticeably louder than the 980 under
load it's not overly distracting by any
means and it's certainly quieter than
AMD's cards but it's something to bear
in mind if noise is a big issue for you
onto performance then and no surprises
here the GTX Titan X is the fastest
single GPU I've ever tested across the
board there's between a twenty-five and
thirty percent boost in performance over
the 980 and up to 40 percent over an AMD
r9 290x at 1440p the Tizen X pushed
above 60 frames per second in all the
games we tested including yes Crysis 3
going to 4k still showed impressive
results and with the exception of Crysis
3 this time around no game dropped below
40 frames per second the Titan X is the
first card where you can reasonably play
in 4k without having to go with an SLI
or crossfire setup so as expected the
Titan X is now the fastest GPU on the
block and while no GPU is ever really
future proof with 12 gigabytes of vram
onboard it's likely that you'll be able
to keep the Titan X around a while
longer and your average graphics card
and really that's who the Titan X is for
the guy or gal who won't accept anything
less than the very best in performance
this is an enthusiast grade graphics
card with enthusiast pricing to match
but even if you don't take into account
all the great Nvidia extras you get for
the cash g-sync GeForce experience and
game works the Titan X is finally a
generational leap of performance over
the 7 Series and the absolute best
graphics card money can buy